oh my gosh it's delicious it's packed
with protein and fat and it's a driver
of global climate change that's right
this is beef but what if we all just
stop eating it how would it affect your
health and would not eating beef have
global consequences this is what if and
here's what would happen if everyone ate
beans instead of beef not only is beef a
huge part of regional diet and culture
it's also a large part of the United
States economy contributing around 165
billion dollars according to a 2014
economic analysis it's a growing
industry with nearly 13 billion
kilograms of US beef being produced
annually the largest of any country in
the world seems great for business
except for the fact that beef releases
37 percent of all human induced
atmospheric methane in the US alone
human induced methane is defined as
methane brought about by our human
behaviors and activities and beef along
with other livestock production is
responsible for more greenhouse gas
emissions than all the cars planes and
trains in the world there's definitely a
lot tied into the beef production
industry so how would a switch from beef
to beans affect the u.s. how would it
affect the rest of the world
beam's don't often get the spotlight but
maybe they should these seeds yeah their
seeds are loaded with protein and fiber
but are way lower in fat saturated fats
and cholesterol than animal products
fiber which 97% of Americans don't get
enough of can help control weight blood
glucose and cholesterol beans are also
light on the wallet much cheaper than
beef 1/2 kilogram of pinto beans costs
about $1 20 while the same amount of
lean ground beef now typically costs
around 570 Shechinah and while beef is a
good source of minerals vitamin b12 and
protein too much of it can put you more
at risk of heart disease certain cancers
and digestive issues the American Heart
Association and the American Institute
for cancer research both suggests do you
eat more plants and less meat so
substituting beans for beef would
probably be a huge boon to your health
but other than your health and bank
account
how would making the switch from beef to
beans affect the rest of the world in
2018 the Intergovernmental Panel on
Climate Change stated that we only have
until 2030 to stop the globe from
warming to a level over one and a half
degrees more than pre-industrial era
temperatures beyond that and the risk of
droughts floods extreme heat and poverty
will increase drastically that doesn't
sound too optimistic for the future of
our world so where does beef figure into
all this
well while people usually focus on
carbon dioxide as the bad boy of
greenhouse gases methane and nitrous
oxide are also major players more than
half of these non co2 emissions come
from you guessed it livestock farming
single cow can burp and fart up to 320
liters of methane gas every day without
the demand for beef the global
population of over 1 and a half billion
cows would decrease significantly
reducing the amount of methane released
into our atmosphere methane traps heat
in the Earth's atmosphere and has 23
times more warming potential than carbon
dioxide less cows means less methane and
that would help slow rising temperatures
across the globe but it doesn't stop
there it takes 15,000 liters of water to
produce just one kilogram of beef that's
twice the amount of water needed for
pork production and three times the
amount needed for chicken kidney beans
only need 1500 liters which is a tenth
of the amount of water required for beef
consuming beans instead of beef could
help alleviate any water scarcity
looming in the near future beans also
use much less land just one twentieth of
land per unit of protein consumed
compared to beef seeing as 35 percent of
all US farm operations are beef farms
switching the beans would free up a lot
of land but what would happen to that
land and what would happen to the
ranchers who make their livelihood off
of beef production well
the newly available land could be turned
into parks and wild areas or it could be
used to grow other types of food which
could help mitigate growing food demand
both the ranchers and the US economy
would take a serious blow we'd have to
figure out a way for ranchers to
transition from a tradition based
livelihood to something else now in
reality we probably wouldn't start
eating beans instead of beef all at once
and this period of transition would
hopefully give us time to figure out
ways to lessen the impact on ranchers
and the economy but the pros of eating
instead of beef far out reach the cons
and that's just if you give a beef not
all meat even if you make the choice to
face beef out slowly it's a great way to
begin your personal fight against
climate change
sometimes global occurrences can seem
out of our control but what we eat is
something we actually have major power
over and hey we're not saying you have
to go vegan because well that's a story
for another what if
[Music]